I would happily play uh Nigel in The
Devil Wears Prada again do you think
there's a doubles Prada sequel there I
think they talked about it yeah a lot
but I'm not seeing anything happening
yet yeah and I can go in on this like
Nate is the real villain of that movie
by the way yeah right yeah such a jerk
he's not supportive of his woman at all
I know I know but he's afraid he was
afraid it's such an honor to talk to you
but I want to bring up so many different
roles which one as of late have fans
said to you the most like I feel like on
Tick Tock people have been recreating
the spell it with your peas scene from
Easy A
spell it with your p
do it I will take that challenge I like
that yeah I love that movie I think
there are a number of them The Devil
Wears proud is one that people really
really love they love big night and they
love Julie and Julia a lot but I think
probably The Devil Wears Prada is one
that that character they love that love
that character is is there a quote that
surprised you that is like caught on
that people say well you've gerd your
loins is what everyone wants all right
everyone gird your loins
to say and wants me to say yeah is there
a character you'd love to play again and
one that you definitely wouldn't I would
not play George Harvey again in The
Lovely Bones that was horrible it's a
wonderful movie but it was a tough
experience simply because of the role
I'd play Paul child again when we did um
Julie and Julia The Lovely Bones one I
see that clip come up a lot too because
I'm always I don't know I'm on Stanley
2G Tech talk I guess
in the comments I was like I cannot
believe this is Stanley Juju because I
love him so much it's like almost hard
to watch yeah I know and I asked Peter
Jackson why he cast me in that role I
tried to get out of playing the role
which was crazy because everyone needed
a job I was like why do you want me I
don't
and he said because you're funny and I
thought okay but I understand what he
was saying like in a people love you so
you'd be the unassuming yeah and just I
think what he meant was that I thought I
wouldn't be serious about it but that I
wouldn't be overly dramatic about it
that I would throw it away a bit yeah
which is what you have to do when you're
playing somebody who's that awful right
you can't play into it then you know
it's over like the movie's over yeah you
just have to play against it I remember
in promising a woman Greta garlic was
talking about how she cast a bunch of
like lovable people to play the jerks
because it was like whoa yeah I assume
they're terrible people well a lot of
times the people who played really awful
people are really really nice no they're
all bad
was a myth who you were was Citadel a
spy agency loyal to no Nation this was
my favorite thing on your Wikipedia page
it says Stanley Tucci plays an array of
roles from menacing to sophisticated and
I was like that's so accurate but where
does this man fall where does orlick
fall somewhere in the middle of all of
that he's all of that I think there's a
sophistication to him when it comes to
his uh you know sort of technical
prowess uh there's a menace to him
because he is somebody who has been in
the field and goes into the field every
now and again and isn't afraid of
conflict physical conflict and he's
quite ruthless when he has to be
in order to achieve what it needs to
achieve are we going to see you getting
on the action I can't answer that
question
yeah just like that just like that
that's about the extent of it yeah
that's about it yeah that's what I do
among your cast who do you think would
make the actual Best Buy I don't know
Richard says he would be a terrible spy
a Priyanka says she would be a bad spy I
haven't asked Leslie yet about what she
thinks I'll find out I guess if we're
going behind the scenes like the russos
have kept a lot of secrets in their
lives so they did endgame and all that
yeah they could be surprised you guys
get some amazing spy gadgets in the show
if you could make one a reality and have
it for your everyday life which spy
gadget would you like to have I can't
remember what they were in the show but
there was that thing that is like the
Hologram where you can bring up the
that's the one Richard said that he'd
like I wouldn't mind that one I've
already heard like there are spin-offs
planned other things that I feel like
you are the glue you're the center of
the Citadel um so what excites you most
about the possibilities of the universe
that can be expanded here oh my God all
of them I'm excited about all of it I
think this is an incredible thing that
they've conceived and executed I don't
know how you do it the scope of it the
scale of it is enormous the complexity
of it and then the sort of all these
crossovers that probably will happen at
some point they're kind of amazing uh so
I'm excited about all of it
foreign